donc là moi j'ai mon bateau voilà je dis
que c'est mon bateau parce que c'est
vrai que ces bateaux que j'ai eu moi
dans les années soixante dix huit
exactement à noël on pourrait dire des
rickshaws qu'il est un grand enfant ce
passionné collectionne des jouets de son
enfance de sa passion naissent des
expositions comme menez en 70 ça
s'adresse à tout le monde
donc autant plus petit qu plus qu est
née et que aux gens qui ont vécu ces
deux là en tant qu'enfant pour montrer à
leurs enfants avec elle jouait il
pouvait jouer à l'époque des années 70
immanquablement vous êtes un petit peu
près aux tripes parce que c'est les
jouets de votre enfance en tout cas pour
ce qui me concerne moi c'étaient les
petits soldats hier fixes qui sont au
premier étage
ainsi vous avez la lune qui est au
dessus de nous donc tout un tas de
choses qui me rappelle des bons
souvenirs
un voyage dans le temps et dans l'espace
à l'aube des années 70 un événement a
marqué la planète
le premier pas de l'homme sur la lune
une inspiration pour créer l'exposition
on se dit mais que faisait des enfants à
l'époque à quoi il joue et on a voulu
faire un focus à la fois en briques lego
sur cet événement majeur les années 70
sur l'homme qui a marché sur la lune
mais aussi sur les jouets qui pourraient
accompagner ses enfants à l'époque à
travers leurs loisirs et leurs plaisirs
il ne reste plus qu'à enfiler vos tenues
de spationaute et laissez vous voyagez
m
[Musique]
soit
ouais
[Musique]